first on CBS this morning we always like
when that happens I'm gonna say it again
first on CBS this morning the Library of
Congress has just revealed its newest
National ambassador for young people's
literature the two-year position aims to
raise the nation's appreciation of youth
literature as it relates to literacy
education and the development and
betterment of our lives our nation's
newest national ambassador for young
people's literature you're looking at
him this is Jason Reynolds hello Jason
Reynolds yeah he is a best-selling an
award-winning author and poet whose work
includes patina and his brave as you my
favorite is long way down I love love
love that book he writes for young adult
audiences
Jason was named to the position by the
librarian of Congress she's here - hello
Carla hello I don't know who's more
excited meet Carla or Jason we are now
divided by both of them in our Toyota
greenroom so you want to talk about your
engagement first that's a private joke
with me and Jason bugging like when's a
news coming but okay all right mr.
ambassador tell us what this position
means to you and what you intend to do
with it cuz this is a big job Jason it's
a big job
so what it means to me is accountability
accountability responsibility compassion
and empathy to remember that our young
people are young people and that they
are the most human parts of our humanity
but a lot of people think young people
don't read or not reading because a lot
of levels are down a little bit yeah I
also think I think that that people
think that mainly because for a few
reasons one I think statistics are
always tricky right because I think that
that statistical narrative can be
controlled by the person who is
articulating it right whatever you see
in those numbers is what you see it
doesn't mean if they're not necessarily
true they're just not hold truths and
that and that I think readership is up
and maybe we haven't quite made the
connection between the readership and
the test scores and maybe they're we
should sort of start to analyze about
analyze our curriculums and other things
there's a bigger sort of thing at play
it's not just about the young people
it's about all the other things but
there's but I believe readership from
what I'm seeing on the ground that
readership is actually way way yes
you're there Carla listen you had a lot
of people to choose from what were you
looking for an ambassador and how
did you end up with him curly he's very
bright very articulate and really knows
his stuff but like him the empathy the
ability to reach all types of young
people I've seen him with hundreds of
young people I've seen lines I knew two
hours long I have young people waiting
to talk with him to really say that this
book touched me and they don't look like
Jason all the time mm-hmm and so we
wanted an ambassador are supposed to
have and make good relations mm-hmm and
be that bridge for people and that's
what we really want but Jason and I've
done stories with Jason that's why I'm
already very smitten before we even
start this I was thrilled when I saw
though that you had chosen him but Jason
I remember your own personal story you
didn't read or you didn't really finish
a book until you were 17 at the time I
said to him Carl I don't know whether to
be impressed or mad you haven't read a
book the whole book something over
seventeen but what would it have taken
for you Jason what could somebody have
said to you that would have made you
think reading is cool reading is fun I
think I think if we were to look at
reading the same way we look at career
day in our schools right the reason that
so many kids want to be firefighters
when they're young is because
firefighters come to the school during
their rare day and teachers they
intervene to interact with every single
day doctors and show up to the school
lawyers show up to the school writers
never came and so I want ball players
right you want to be a basketball player
cuz you see basketball players you want
to be an MC because you see rappers
around you want to be a musician right
and so my thing is if we could make some
of us more public if we can engage with
young people in a 1:1 level face-to-face
really ask them questions and
furthermore listen to what they have to
say to acknowledge their humanity
I think young people are willing to
invest in you in a different way once
they once they feel like they can trust
you is that what you plan to do to go
interact with people face of it and
where do you plan to go I mean that's
always been my goal it's always been
what I've done and and this time around
I plan to go primarily it's a small town
in rural America because I always say I
always profess that I love children but
that can't be true if I don't love all
of them yeah that can't be true like
it's a real thing you know
I don't think they've seen a lot of
people that look like you in rural
America all the more reason to go yeah
that's the ambassador role
yeah that's he's going to go and show
here is what an author can be concerned
because the reality is that no matter
what I feel the way anyone feels about
these places there are children there
yeah period yeah there are children and
children are children everywhere on the
planet yeah all children uh-huh I love
what you said everyone's so concerned
should they not be concerned it's such
polarizing times I think there's in this
country yes big and and and we're so the
vitriol is so heavy intense I'm not I
think that concern is warranted yeah but
well I don't live my life in fear right
because if I live my life in fear then
we stop what we're trying to proliferate
to young people we stop it and they're
the ones who pay for it on the back end
so if we actually want to see a change
if we really say believe the things that
we say then we have to go and talk to
the children so that as they grow they
close the chasm but if all of us are
afraid to talk to the kids yeah we can't
expect the world to look differently 20
years I know I know you're right I would
love to go there reading a very chatty
person I play nicely with others too
Jason
I know they're reading in the rural
areas they're reading Jason no I lived
in Turkey as a kid from first grade to
sixth grade we didn't have television
nobody did so for me going to the
library I had a light the thing called a
library card you would go and check out
books oh I was a voracious reader I
loved reading it can take you places
what would be your definition of success
Carla at the end of two years for
Jason's ambassadorship if when he goes
into those communities he gets young
people to tell their stories his
platform is grab a mic Mantralayam grab
a mic and tell your story and we will
add hundreds of young people's stories
to our American Folklife Center we have
X people who have done Veterans Affairs
all these things in this folk life but
what about the voices of young
you know and they keep saying this is
not a political role but you write a lot
about politics and about social issues
do you intend to do anything with that
I mean it's yet to be seen first of all
I think that I live a political life
right but I just think the way that we
think about what that means is it has a
negative connotation but but like me
being in a space is a political thing me
making these decisions our political
decisions right yeah it is what it is
and that's okay this is a good thing and
and without right about it I typically
am a person who works for me inside out
this will be a part of my inside now and
so will it come out in the work I'm sure
what are you reading now that really
excites you oh goodness what am i
reading there at the moment it's not one
of your novels no no be my own after
treating you don't read it again yeah I
definitely don't I just finished a
little while ago I think it went but
there really stuck with me was and it's
it's not a quote-unquote children's book
I miss Jacqueline Woodson's right at the
bone oh yeah and she wanting book it is
haunting I loved what Jacqueline said
about you she was talking about you know
when Jason speaks and the the effect
that you have on people she said this in
in the New York Times about Jason kids
have not been exposed to a writer who
looks like he does who sounds like he
does who has a deep honesty in
connection with them that he does and he
really sees those kids wrap inspired
your writing how so for a few reasons
one it showed me that that rap music was
poetry and that poetry was mine and that
if poetry could be mine then story could
be mine narrative could be mine my
identity could be mine and could be
valuable to it showed me that
irreverence wasn't a bad thing yeah
right that there's a thin line between
irreverence and irresponsibility but
that irreverence is okay and I try to be
irreverent in my work and the way it's
written in the language is written in
and and what I choose to talk about
and then lastly language itself right
it's malleable and it bends and it's
fluid and it's evolving and I get
play with it however I choose yeah it is
mine yeah that's amazing
no I'm telling you for the first time I
met him I thought God you're a sound
byte a minute you hear about his life
story and then how he tells the story
I doubt you do you give me goosebumps
when you speak but limit can we do a
quick lightening or how much time you
antsy do we have okay a quick lightning
round for both of you before we let you
go Jason if you had to pick one book to
read over and over and over again what
would it be
autobiography market mix okay Carla a
book that you're looking forward to
reading right at the bone jacqueline
woodson I have it for that Jason a book
that changed your life though a new
person with the eyes are watching God
right
Carla a book that doesn't get enough
recognition if the old streak could talk
the movie oh yeah it was wonderful but
if you read James Baldwin and I have an
autographed copy that he read from years
ago and I got showing off yeah well what
a treasure what a treasure and I don't
put it where people that visit my house
can see it may I say you have excellent
taste
yeah we're making the selection
congratulations mr. ambassador always
good to see you really good to see you
that'll do it for us we thank you for
joining us on Facebook live by